Oh [Music]  a death-defying trapeze act gone wrong  on the first night of America's Got  Talent's season 13 judges cuts acrobatic  couple Mary entice of duo transcend how  to slip up which left Mary on the floor  [Applause]  Tice who is nearly blind and meri have  been married for six years and share a  two-year-old son who was in the audience  after a suspenseful commercial break  meri left to her feet waving to the  crowd and asked for another shot we  would like to try the boy mo trick one  more time to which the judges responded  it's not America's Got perfection this  is America's Got Talent  no one can do this I don't think there's  ever been a sinner on any of our  competitions who's been no perfect and  the fact that you're Lily blind makes  this incredible as for the outcome six  more acts are gonna make it through  you're gonna be in the mix guys well  done congratulations  [Applause]